if you have never experienced severe  illness you can't understand it even  when you see it and sometimes that means  that when you see it it makes you angry  so a lot of these poor suffering people  who are chronically ill who are going  i'm hurt i'm hurt i'm hurt look how hurt  i am people are just like stop stop it  stop it stop it i don't want to be  around that and it's probably some sort  of evolutionary response to avoid  infection i don't know what it is but  sick people get a lot of hate for being  sick well it's frustration too on the  part of the people yeah and sadness  right and it's a lot easier to be angry  at somebody than sad at them